non c'est typique ça si tu l'entends
alors bon trimestre méchante hakuna
matata en classe la brèche de carphone
bonjour comme vous pouvez le constater
notre cher prof manque d'inspiration en
ce moment c'est pourquoi il n'y aura pas
de nouvel épisode avant les fêtes j'en
suis la première désolé mais je vous
promets de la part seul et avec la
musique du générique jusqu'à ce qu'elle
se mette au travail
cette finesse en attendant je vous
souhaite de bonnes fêtes de fin d'année
et pour vous faire patienter jusqu'à
l'épisode de janvier j'ai décidé de
révéler tous les moments un peu nul de
nos tournage juste après ce message
portez vous bien passer de bonnes fêtes
et comme on dit chez moi victoria moon
10.10 lacrima et d'autres enfin n'avait
rien à voir avec la choucroute mais
décidé de réaliser une prédiction pour
apprendre genre de visas aux services de
charles le téméraire réalise une
prédiction en violences
en mélange puisqu'on considère que les
français se sont fait écraser parce
qu'ils étaient moins patriote que les
allemands ils pouvaient être équipés de
hache mais c'était plutôt des armes de
jet après ça va
l'étude de clovis notamment son baptême
permet par exemple de montrer l'unité
crédit c'est trop facile
ils sont tellement mauvais ça sera un
crime de se priver
on préfère également se concentrer sur
une histoire globale
non mr dont le chêne inverse mais on ne
sait pas si je suis bon je filme ses
oies tigana jean louis conan des carpes
renvoyé il pouvait être équipés de hache
mais elles étaient plutôt des zones de
jeu et c'est un peu moi j'ai parlé des
making-of outre comme ça ouais j'en
ferai un jour
à la fin du xième siècle à la fin
du ça me fait chier à la fin du
10ème siècle les scandinaves se
convertissent au catholicisme au
christianisme
s'il y avait eu un troisième en pierron
pas merde
bonjour cunégonde cosplayeuses
professionnel j'ai soif
je reviens allait s'annoncer d'abord et
ouais
on peut donc pas désigné comme picking
l'ensemble de la population scandinaves
et on leur a aussi donné des tentes y
dénombre demandé d'aider d'autres formes
et lance pas en vue c'est bon à se dire
merde bonjour pourrions-nous ne peut
mais un troisième test et après c'est
parti
c'est
ce trait qui se bougent c'est
fantastique c'est notamment le cas de
l'état de snri qui est l'une des
principales sources sur la mythologie de
la métallerie l'habitacle xinhua le
tramway qui est fantastique et web
techno raquette il pouvait être équipés
de hache mais c'était plutôt des armes
de fait les guerres vivement